there is this sense sometimes of the way  of me making change is to be as  judgmental as possible about other  people  folks this is verbatim the stuff I've  been saying for four years on the show  these are genuinely wise words I've been  careful to say there is a small but very  loud part of the left  the right is almost completely Bonkers  nuts okay that's clear that's a clear  part of the show  but there is this slice of the left  that's very loud  and they will allow the perfect to  become the enemy of the good  they will use Purity tests they will  dismiss entire groups of people over uh  the narcissism of what we sometimes call  small differences and in my universe in  the left media platform they often try  to ruin what people like me and others  are doing because we're not perfect by  their standard